this aircraft brought the first sign of
good news for millions of iranians since
the start of the pandemic nearly a year
ago
the russian sputnik vaccines are the
first batch to arrive
and there are two more shipments coming
later this month
these jobs will be given to 430 000
healthcare workers before anyone else
and iran has so far purchased two
million doses of the russian vaccine
russia's sputnik v's efficacy is 91 to
93
considering that the sputnik is designed
well and its second doses are stronger
than the first doses
we expect 91 to 92 efficacy in our
country
more importantly the sputnik v prevents
death in very serious cases of the
disease
one hundred percent iran is the worst
affected country in the middle east
with nearly 60 000 covet 19 deaths
and more than 1.4 million people
infected
this shipment comes at a critical time
when the country is trying to avoid
another wave
ahead of the iranian new year in
mid-march that's a time when families
visit each other in large numbers
president hassan rouhani has warned iran
cannot afford another lockdown
and he's urging the public to continue
to observe protocols
set out by health officials iranian
scientists have also been working on
their own vaccine
two of which are now in human trial
phases and officials are hopeful
they will be rolled out in the next few
months
despite severe economic sanctions on
iran's banking sectors
officials say they have purchased 18
million doses of foreign vaccines
but not those made in the u.s or britain
supreme leader ayatollah ali khamenei
has banned the import of vaccines made
in those countries
saying they cannot be trusted on
thursday iran recorded 67
deaths that's the lowest number in the
past eight months
but there's still a long way to go
before the officials here
are able to um vaccinate large number of
people
they're hoping that they will be able to
do that by
the beginning of next year mid 2022
um and that's when they hope there will
be some relief for the millions of
iranians that have been affected by this
pandemic
dorsa thanks very much dorsa jabari
reporting live there from
tehran nadine baba joins us live here on
the newshour from saint thomas's
hospital
in london so nadine they're going to try
mixing
different vaccines how do they know if
it works
well to be honest uh they don't know as
yet i'm at actually at um
guys hospital in london where they're
already vaccinating
some of the the local population but the
government are now
saying that they're going to work with
oxford university
in a world first trial they want over
800 volunteers
aged more than 50 people who haven't had
a jab
and they're going to give them a first
dose of either the oxford astrazeneca
vaccination or the pfizer beyond tech
vaccination
and then they'll get a second one within
12 weeks
that could be the same or it could be an
alternative vaccination
so they want to find out whether
protection is actually
worse the same or even better
if you get a mixture of vaccines they're
saying that other
vaccines could be involved such as the
um
norovax and the yanson vaccines once
they're approved as well
and the scientists in this study are
hoping that it could give them clues
as to how to fight better against those
variants as well
which have emerged not just here but in
south africa and brazil
but this plan won't have a negative
impact
on the vaccine rollout in the uk anyway
which is going
really quite well especially compared to
some other european countries
that's a fair point peter britain really
is being seen as an example by many
countries in europe
it's got a more than 11 million people i
think vaccinated
as of now uh it's on plan to
get the first four priority groups done
with their first dose
by the middle of the month um but nadim
zahawi the
government minister for vaccines has
said uh
that um there are globally 4 000
roughly variants of the virus
and for that reason scientists here are
putting together what he's called a
library
of these mutations so that they can be
ready to react to any
developments in future he's pointed out
that people like pfizer beyond tech
are already trying to adapt existing
vaccines
to be ready to adapt to any mutations
he's also warned that
he's worried that although 85 percent of
the population here
say they will get the vaccine the rest
the 15
is skewed towards people who are in the
so-called bain community black and
minority ethnic groups
and this the worrying figure at the
moment is that people
in britain who are either black british
or african
uh nationality say are twice
as unlikely twice less likely to have
received the jab so
far compared to the white british
population
so nadim zahawi says that the government
is going to try to get
figures from the national health service
on ethnicity
and try to get into local communities to
really improve that situation
nadine thanks very much nadine baba
there reporting live from guys hospital
in london